how's it going everybody it's warm
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about everything
Marvel and all things relating to the
MCU and today we're going to talk about
Captain America a big question about the
future of the MCU especially when it
comes to phase 4 and the Falcon and the
Winter Soldier is is Captain America
going to return is Chris Evans going to
reprise his role and appear in a few
episodes some people want him back some
people don't some people think that his
ending was perfect and now he's done
some people think they know the answer
as there has been a little bit of rumors
about him coming back but recently Chris
Evans set everything straight and told
us whether or not captain is coming back
for sure
or not before we dive into it real quick
the winner of last week's spider-man
Funko pop giveaway is Colin b25 for
congratulations and I know everybody is
wondering what this week's giveaway is
going to be this week is going to be a
Hulk Funko pop all you have to do to
enter is be subscribed to my channel
like this video and leave a comment
about the video down below so Chris
Evans was recently on the Graham Norton
Show where of course he was asked if
he's coming back as Captain America and
he had a lot of well-thought-out things
to say when asked if it was too risky to
come back as Captain America he said yes
I think it is it was a great run and we
went out on such a high note that it
would be risky to revisit it in my
opinion it was such a good experience
and I think it's better left that way
now this seems like a definitive no
however last November he did say that
there were some cases in which he would
consider coming back he said it's not a
hard no but it's not an eager yes either
there are other things that I'm working
on right now
I think cap had such a tricky act to
stick the landing and I think they did a
really nice job letting him complete his
journey if you're going to revisit it it
can't be a cash grab it can't be just
because the audience wants to be excited
what are we revealing what are we adding
to the story a lot of things would have
to come together it doesn't feel at this
time that would be a thing it would be a
shame to sour that talking about Steve's
ending and Avengers end game I'm very
protective of it it was such a precious
time and jumping onto the movie was
a terrifying prospect to me I said no a
bunch of times and there's a million and
one ways it could have gone wrong it
almost feels like maybe we should let
this one sit so as you can see Chris
Evan seems to think that Captain America
is ending in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe seems to be perfect and I'm
sure a lot of people would agree he
finally got to settle down he finally
got to be with and marry Peggy Carter we
can assume that they had kids and he
lived his life out a happy man but if he
doesn't come back this means one of two
things happened after Avengers in game
one is that Captain America when he gave
the shield to Sam went back to his
original timeline now I know there was a
bait between the directors and the
riders on which timeline he was really
in whether it was the main one or
whether it was a separate one that was
newly created but if it was a separate
timeline we can assume that he either
went back to that timeline or he stayed
in the current timeline and eventually
died even with the Super Soldier Serum
he was very old at the end of Avengers
in game and we can assume that he lived
way past Peggy Carter because she didn't
have the serum so he lived a good long
life with his wife and now it's time for
him to be done of course the other
option could be that he is still alive
and could make an appearance as an old
man Captain America in the Falcon and
the Winter Soldier series now this seems
less likely after what he said but if he
was going to make an appearance it would
be in one of these shows however as it
seems right now it looks like Captain
America is done in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe until we get a new version of a
new Captain America down the line so let
me know what you think about this would
you like to see his character return or
do you agree with Chris Evans and that
they gave him the perfect ending let me
know in the comments down below don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
so you can stay up to date on everything
related to the MCU
you can also follow me on Twitter for
live updates and as always thank you all
so much for watching we'll fluff